I chose to tackle the problem of visual
transduction
because I wanted to find out
how does how does the excitation of
rhodopsin
lead
to a physiologic consequence
now at the time we knew that there was
signaling that went uh to the other
cells of the retina and eventually to
the optic nerve but we did not really
know what was the change in the retinal
Rod outer segment but it seemed to me
that this was a very attractive object
of inquiry because here the outer
segment of the rod cell that's our dim
light receptor is is packaged with the
entire transduction machinery
so you know if you take a retina
and uh
detached and just shake it like that the
outer segments fall off
and you can in a fairly in a day's work
you can Harvest
the Machinery that carries out the
transduction process and so uh it
occurred to me that this would be a
wonderful way to get into the problem
and we then decided that
the way we could enter the problem the
way that we might be able to make
progress
is to look
for a guanine nucleotide binding protein
in Rod outer segments
that is the experiments of Lehman
indicated that not only light was needed
for the activation
of the cyclic GMP phosphodiesterase
but GTP guanosine triphosphate was also
needed
and so
we decided
to look for a GTP or GDP binding protein
because we thought you know such a
protein could be the intermediary
between photo excited rhodopsin and the
cyclic GMP phosphodiesterase they had to
be a link
and the requirement for GTP
really gave us a clue of what the link
might be now at the very same time
people studying hormone action people
like Al Gilman
Rod Bell and others were seeing that GDP
was needed
in hormone action that the hormone
itself was not enough
to elicit the characteristic biological
response but that there had to be a GTP
binding component and that led to the
birth of G proteins so this was going on
in the background and it was certainly
in the back of our minds
and
so we decided to look for a guanine
nucleotide binding activity in the rod
outer segment
and the experiment that Bernard Bernard
phone carried out
was to incubate Rod outer segments
with
uh radioactively labeled GTP now the
position of the label is important
uh it was the alpha alpha phosphorus the
innermost phosphorus that was labeled
with p32
and so that would enable us to detect
either
GTP or GDP Bernard then incubated the
rod outer segments with the radio
labeled GTP
and then washed away
all of the GTP and then asked was there
any radioactivity left
in the rod outer segments
and he found indeed there was
and what had happened was
that the GTP that he put in we now know
got converted
to GDP guanosine diphosphate
and
that was what was permanently bound to
the rod outer segments permanent in the
sense that Bernard was able to pull it
down by centrifuging it
and then in very short order he carried
out
a really incisive series of experiments
first he found that the uh
that the entry
of GTP into
some binding site on the wrought iron
segment
required light that it wasn't enough
just to have the GTP there
and it was that finding that enabled
Bernard
to make the very important quantitative
study where he looked at the exchange
process and it showed that the kinetics
of jtp Entry coincided
with GDP going out
strongly suggesting that there was an
exchange process and it was an exchange
process that required light to trigger
it
Bernard then went on and asked well how
effective is light
in leading to this exchange process
and then there was a wonderful moment
where we were looking at the data and
saw that it was just a tiny amount of
light that was needed we found that for
a single
photo excited rhodopsin there was an
exchange of 500
gtps for bound gdps this was the key
finding this was the first time
that we saw that rhodopsin was doing
something that led to a high degree of
amplification in a very direct sense